you know I've been born I was born in
this brought up in the 60s you know it
was at a time where well it was a hippie
time so I wore long hair I wore the
clothes that I wanted to you know wanted
to wear it was a time when people cared
about minority groups you know the you
know the gay community became accepted
by you know but by people in the 60s see
the lesbian community they you know it
was it was a you know a time of
embracing people embracing embracing
society embracing each other and I like
to think that's rubbed off on me and and
one of the Sex Pistols songs was
something along the lines of old hippies
never never die and think I'm an old
hippie and I hopefully I'll never die
heater I think I adventure side was
important because because it helped put
the Virgin Group on the map it helped to
put myself on the map it was great fun
and we were trying to do things that you
know man had never done before and you
know the trying to work out the
technology to get a balloon to cross the
Atlantic and then to achieve that then
then to the Pacific and then to try to
go around the world and the camaraderie
of working with people the having to
deal with you know extremely dangerous
situations and you know managing to cope
through those and so it was I think it
was an important chapter in my life but
the came a time well you know where you
know we with that where that it helped I
think made the Virgin Group very
successful and and I decided you know I
didn't want to waste you know wastes the
position that we'd found ourselves in
and you know with wealth comes enormous
responsibility and
and capitalism has enormous faults i'm
going to say this the only system that
seems to work but it also throws up this
enormous wealth tennis players you know
10 tennis players enormously wealthy
thousands of tennis players very poor
and you know in a basketball players
football is the same you know rite
throughout society you've got this
extreme extreme wealth that's great for
created by capitalism so if you're one
of those lucky people who you know who
are in that position where you get that
extreme wealth and you know you've just
got to make sure that wealth goes back
to society in some form or another
whether it's creating more jobs or
whether it's you know tak of tackling
the problems of the world that money
must not languish in a you know in a
bank account and be unproductive I don't
think it was an overnight though because
someone if I go back to the 60s and you
know I set up a a center for young
people and when I realized that young
people you know who you know maybe got
pregnant too you know habanero disease
who lonely was suicidal had nowhere to
go and that you know that taught me you
know that you know that you can make a
better you can make a big difference and
you know for relatively small amount of
money you can you can make a big
difference to a lot of people's lives
and and says over the years I think we
have continued in that spirit but we've
never really had the resources to really
make a difference and we never really
you know I never really had the party
will say you know pick up the phone to
you know Clinton or Mandela or you know
whoever in the world and get straight
through and get things done so so now
I'm in that position and it would be
very sad to waste that position and and
you know just to carry on you know
trying to accumulate wealth and more and
more wealth and and you know it's
important we have the Virgin machine to
generate the world but then it's very
important not not and it's also very
impor
for the staff worker virgin to know that
that wealth is going to be spent in a
constructive way and that's really hard
to do
you